the history of Venice Italy is
inextricably linked to water it was once
the capital of a seafaring Empire and
its residents have always gotten around
by bogut instead of car
but lately those very waters have become
an extreme threat due to frequent
massive flooding this week a long
planned and controversial technology is
being tested that could address the
problem Chris lives say reports 78
barriers are all that stand between 1500
years of culture and destruction in the
first full-blown test of the flood
prevention system it was Italian Prime
Minister Jews epic cult day who launched
the slowest gates we all have to hope
that it works he said a hope and a
prayer
it's called mosai a reference to Moses
who in the Old Testament parted the sea
perched atop soggy islands and wooden
piles Venice has been slowly sinking
since its inception in the fifth century
and is subject to routine flooding
rising sea levels and high tides
triggered the worst in more than 50
years last November streets and shops
inundated by chest high water this year
it's too much centuries-old artworks
inside st. mark's basilica destroyed
hundreds of millions of euros in damage
a catastrophe in a city that survives
off its beauty and the tens of millions
of tourists who visit every year a
catastrophe that could have been avoided
if only mozi had been completed a decade
ago when it was scheduled but production
has been slowed down by mechanical
failures corruption scandals and arrests
that even included a former mayor of the
city now the engineers say it will be
ready by 2021 but many experts warn mozi
after going billions over-budget
may be inadequate to withstand the ever
higher and ever more frequent tides
rocked by climate change for CBS this
morning Saturday Chris lives a row
[Applause]